[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici
depuis strasbourg depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme une émission
spéciale entièrement consacré aux
briques site et nous prendrons la
direction de l'ecosse avec la
perspective d'une sortie
les écossais sont de plus en plus
nombreux à arriver d'indépendance
notamment pour pouvoir rester dans
l'union européenne car le breakbeat a
révélé avant tout une crise politique au
royaume uni le break site sonnera-t-il
l'éclatement du royaume uni comment
éviter de raviver les tensions entre les
deux irlande
nous ouvrirons le débat avec nos invités
en plateau mais avant son retour sur cet
accord de sortie longuement négocié
jusqu'à la dernière minute entre les 27
états membres et boris johnson qu'y at
il de nouveau dans ce traité de divorce
quelles sont les nouvelles dispositions
négociées
éléments de réponse avec aurélie d'afas
[Musique]
535 pages pour un nouveau traité de
divorce entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne points majeurs renégocié dans
cet accord la question de l'irlande du
nord le fameux bac stop
ce filet de sécurité qui devait
maintenir le royaume uni dans le
territoire douanier de l'union
européenne est abandonné l'irlande du
nord reste donc dans le territoire
douanier britanniques mais les
vingt-sept lui délègue la gestion d'une
partie de leurs droits de douane les
nord-irlandais devons appliquer les
droits de douane européens aux produits
destinés à l'union européenne concernant
la tva
l'irlande du nord continuera à appliquer
les règles de l'union européenne sur son
territoire afin d'éviter une frontière
dur sur l'île l'accord renégocié par
boris johnson avec les vingt-sept
reprend ensuite en grande partie les
points déjà présent dans l'accord
précédent notamment le maintien des
droits de travailler ou encore d'étudier
à la fois pour les citoyens britanniques
présents sur le continent et pour les
européens au royaume uni les deux
parties se sont aussi accordés pour
fixer une période de transition jusqu'au
31 décembre 2020 un temps pendant lequel
les britanniques continueront
d'appliquer et de bénéficier des règles
européennes
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau sylvie guillaume vous êtes
eurodéputée française depuis 2009 et
vous siéger au sein du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates
bienvenue à vous et en arabe vous êtes
également eurodéputés allemands depuis
2004 rattaché au ppe le groupe
conservateur bonjour tout d'abord avant
de parler un petit peu plus précisément
de l'accord qu'on vient de voir dans le
sujet je voudrais avoir votre premier
commentaire le parlement britannique a
approuvé par principe
le nouvel accord mais a refusé la
procédure d'urgence
est ce qu'on peut imaginer une sortie ou
31 octobre sylvie guillaume
ça paraît difficile vu que comme vous
l'indiquez dans votre sujet c'est un
texte compliqué on y reviendra
certainement qu'ils méritent un examen
précis mais il faut bien noter que ce
qui a été voté au parlement britannique
et lire le début du travail sur le reste
et je pense que si nécessaire pour les
députés britanniques de se pencher sur
la complexité de cet accord sur les
questions de concurrence sur les
questions de tva de douane qui en soi
sont sont compliquées donc personne ne
sait pour le moment exactement le temps
que ça prendra
on comprend bien que le premier ministre
britannique veut absolument respecter sa
propre parole mais il n'est pas question
que le parlement européen se laisse
dicter une conduite ou des horaires ou
des délais on prendra le temps qu'il
faut effectivement pour prendre notre
décision toute responsabilité et surtout
ne pas tomber dans un piège aussi que
boris johnson temps régulièrement aux
européens c'est-à-dire de faire le lui
de nous faire prendre la responsabilité
éventuellement d'anodine il n'en est pas
question
en achat vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat il faut encore prendre du temps
pour examiner précisément cet accord oui
car le l'accord qui est maintenant sur
la table a changé profondément
on est en quelque sorte revenues au
début car la commission européenne avait
proposé que l'irlande du nord reste dans
l'union européenne et que la frontière
soit entre l'irlande du nord et la
grande bretagne
et maintenant on est revenus là dessus
donc un certain nombre de questions se
posent maintenant alors justement qu'est
ce qui a fait basculer les choses à
votre avis pour parvenir finalement un
consensus entre les vingt-sept et
maurice vincent riou je pense que cette
histoire fasse est cette négociation est
une négociation très longue très
compliqué très complexe moi je sais gré
à michèle bernier de l'avoir mené au nom
des européens elle avoir mené de cette
manière là parce que je pense qu'un
certain nombre d'entre nous peut-être
les européens se sont dits en 2016 c'est
le début de l' implosion européenne
c'est la première fois qu'un pays
souhaite sortir et pas entrer donc il y
avait fraude potentiellement à risque
dans cette négociation longue a montré
d'une certaine manière
l'unité des européens mais c'est une
discussion très compliqué avec des refus
successifs et finalement je pense que si
elle était recherchée pour une fois
c'est obtenir une réponse positive des
britanniques parce que jusqu'à présent
nous nous heurtons depuis trois ans ab
nos donc la réalité c'est à la volonté
des européens était d'aboutir d'abord
ainsi une sortie ordonnée
parce que comme je disais tout à l'heure
on ne veut pas d'un audit qui serait
très préjudiciable à la fois pour les
britanniques et pour l'union européenne
donc l'idée c'est effectivement
d'obtenir une sortie ordonnée et de s'en
donner les moyens
on va rentrer un petit peu plus dans les
points de l'accord une des nouveautés de
cet accord concerne la frontière entre
les deux irlande on ne parle plus de
bagues stop ce filet de sécurité
l'irlande du nord elle reste donc dans
le territoire douanier britannique à
l'exception des marchandises en
provenance de pays tiers mais destinées
à l'union européenne qui transitent via
l'irlande du nord j'espère que les
téléspectateurs sont encore c'est très
complet et très complexe c'est
applicable ça au quotidien
alors d'abord il faut dire que le bec
stop ça a été une idée mais ce n était
pas une réalité il fallait simplement tu
es encore le bec stop c'était une idée
politique le bec stop c'était que
l'irlande du nord et l'irlande il ya une
sorte frontières ouvertes avec des
contrôles exact c'était une idée on ne
savait pas encore comment le rendre
réalité le faire aurait une réalité
maintenant la solution que le
gouvernement britannique a finalement
accepté c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît déjà
on a le code de douane les gens du der
land du nord l'appliquent déjà car il
est déjà en place
donc pour eux c'est juste de continuer
d'appliquer le code de douane européens
le problème est temps qu'on a toujours
dit aux britanniques qui devrait mieux
l'appliquer déjà dans les dernières
vingt années est donc maintenant il se
pose la question comment on peut faire
confiance aux à la aux autorités de
douane de l'irlande du nord t'appliques
hic en droit européen même s'ils ne sont
plus à ses membres de l'union européenne
parce que de fait l'europe confie en
gros au royaume uni le soin de gérer le
droit douanier européens dont comment on
fait exact surtout de reverser
effectivement ces droits de douane à
l'union européenne s'agissant d'un
certain nombre de produits
donc c'est effectivement une question de
confiance qui devrait être mesurée au
bout d'un certain temps de
fonctionnement pour voir si c'est
réellement la solution la plus efficace
je crois qu'il ya des deadline qui sont
mises justement vérifier cette
conformité avec l'union européenne
alors justement l'accord il prévoit une
période de transition jusqu'à la fin
2020 mais avec la possibilité de
prolonger cette période jusqu'en 2022
pourquoi voir aussi loin et encore
autant de points de détails à régler
il faut d'abord trouver les autorités
l'irlande du nord n'a pas vraiment eu le
besoin de le faire car c'était une
région qui était dans l'union européenne
au futur ils doivent le faire pour
l'union européenne sous contrôle de
l'union européenne avec des lois qui
sont votées ici donc c'est déjà une
grande un grand défi deuxièmement le
problème étant que le premier ministre
britannique avait proposé de faire ça de
plus en plus de manière digitale
malheureusement l'union européenne
discutent depuis 15 ans comment rendre
l'application du code des douanes plus
digital c'est très difficile
on n'est pas encore là on en est pas
encore là donc il y a encore des choses
à faire mais politiquement le problème
reste que le parlement de l'irlande du
nord
une garde une compétence pour toujours
décider sur l'application
alors là ça c'est un problème il faut
discuter des nouveautés c'est le
parlement en effet
l'ong qui ne pourra se prononcer tous
les quatre ans sur le droit à douaniers
applicables est-ce qu'on reste sur le
droit européen où on repasse sur les
droits de douanes britanniques
franchement est-ce que c'est
compréhensible pour les européens c'est
une vidéo c'est assez compliqué y
compris pour les européens léger député
européen et j'y reviens c'est là toute
la densité de cet acord tout ce qui se
passe là on prend à des points qui ne
sont pas des points de détails qui sont
des points très précis mais il faut en
serre et cela dans des vocations de cet
accord plus large comme la négociation
d'un accord commercial c'est ça qui va
se mettre en oeuvre dans l'est dans les
années qui viennent donc l'union
européenne à des règles elle a des
règles sera sanitaire elle a des règles
sur l'environnement elle a des règles
sur la concurrence mais que ceci va
désormais être passés au crible pour
voir si on est en situation d'être
effectivement dans une relation
commerciale équilibrée avec avec le
royaume uni je voudrais savoir est ce
que le parlement roumain il a été
associé dans le cas des négociations sur
le sur le bric site il ya un groupe de
pilotage un du bric site ici qu'est ce
que c'est non on a toujours été inclus
dans le débat michel barnier qui a déjà
mentionné a fait un travail remarquable
aussi de garder ensemble les 27
il a aussi toujours tenu un contact très
très très dense avec le parlement
européen
mais la question pour nous à la fin qui
se pose est ce qu'on peut à cet accord
politique est ce qu'on peut faire
confiance avec les questions autour des
douanes et aussi aux des questions
autour de ce parlement de l'irlande du
nord ulster monde qui depuis trois ans
ne siège plus car les gens ne
s'entendent plus et que ce parlement on
lui donne la responsabilité de
renouveler tous les quatre ans le
renouvellement de la compétence de
prendre en charge des les douanes c'est
quand même un risque politique qui est
seulement limité avec le fait que si le
parlement ne siège pas c'est
automatiquement renouvelé
ça fait pas confiance vraiment de garder
de charger un parlement qui ne siège pas
avec la compétence de renouveler un
accord qu'on a fait entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni c'est quand
même un risque qu'il faut prendre en
considération vos sites
vous avez quelques points d'inquiétude
concernant cet accord globalement il ya
beaucoup de risques dans ce processus il
ya le risque il faut appeler un chat un
chat aussi de l'attitude du premier
ministre britannique
quelquefois un peu erratique on va dire
qu'il ya des décisions personnelles là
qui sont quelquefois difficilement
explicable donc il y à ça il y a la
possibilité de passer de nouveau par les
urnes je signale quand même quand il y a
eu des marches extrêmement importante le
jour même siéger au parlement
britannique d'un million de la venue
d'amiens l'arrêt sera londres qui
viennent dire maintenant nous voulons
non seulement être consultés mais nous
voulons rester ce qui nous est présenté
ne nous convient pas donc il ya tout ça
qui est en ligne de mire la possibilité
d'un nouveau référendum donc et pour
nous comme parlementaire européen la
nomination d'un rapporteur puisque dans
notre mécanique interne on va de nouveau
être associés est au coeur des choses
puisque la commission des affaires
constitutionnelles va nommer un
rapporteur pour lui-même travaillé sur
cet accord donc au bout du bout notons
aussi que le parlement européen va
donner son accord ou pas au début je
pense que oui et puis à la fin aussi
donc c'est un processus démocratique
long compliqué erratique parfois mais
qui est maîtrisée du point de vue des
institutions européennes essaient de
sortir elle aura de toute façon un coup
pour l'union européenne pour tous pour
les citoyens britanniques pour les
européens pour les gens en france et en
allemagne
guillaume le coût pour l'union
européenne alors si vous parlez d'un
coup strictement financier la question
se posera effectivement de savoir si
le royaume-uni paye sa dette qui est
estimé entre 10 et 15 milliards dans le
budget européen ce qui n'est pas
complètement négligeable
et puis dans l'intervalle on a voté un
certain nombre de textes cette semaine
qui permettent de la période
intermédiaire de ne pas pénaliser
citons citons les légions qui bénéficie
justement des règles européennes
les jeunes qui sont en erasmus les gens
qui se sont déplacés
donc tout cela à son protégé pour le
moment mais c'est aussi ce coup là qu'il
faudra estimer
et puis de demander des comptes au
royaume uni merci à tous les deux d'être
venu nous apporter votre éclairage sur
cet accord et nous prenons maintenant la
direction de l'école où les velléités
indépendantistes s'affiche au grand jour
depuis le bric site
pour rappel les cosses avaient
massivement voté pour le maintien dans
l'union européenne lors du référendum en
notre reporter jonathan du priest est
rendu à aberdeen à la rencontre des
cosec imagine plus leur avenir en europe
qu'au sein du royaume uni
[Musique]
en quarante ans de métier jamais stuart
simpson avait vécu pareille incertitudes
à quelques jours du break site cet
agriculteur ne sait pas encore s'il
écoulera normalement ses pommes de terre
censés être livrés en france en
allemagne ou en espagne pour voir qu'il
t'avait avec fight dahlgren here on
travaille en flux tendu si on ne vend
pas notre production rapidement à
l'export on ne pourra plus rien en faire
jean calvé et les acheteurs étrangers
devront aller en trouver ailleurs m et
donc nos pommes de terre ne serviront
qu'à nourrir le bétail
l'école andré fait elles n'auront plus
aucune valeur plusieurs de ses clients
européens ont gelé leurs achats en
attendant que les causes sorte de
l'union
stuart doit écouler 100 tonnes de pommes
de terre autrement ils s'exposent à une
perte sèche de 200000 euros
son exploitation tout entière serait
menacée ne des blacks' voter le jour du
vote du bric site ma ferme valait
environ cinq millions d'euros à la vente
farage aujourd'hui il n'y aurait plus
aucun acheteur hawk infirmiers ne
voudrait de ses terres agricoles à
l'heure actuelle de would be no
barracuda spam
donc pour des gens comme moi c'est une
vie entière de labeur qui est en sursis
ça valait 5 millions d'euros et ça ne
vaut plus rien comme stuart deux
millions d'écossais se distinguent
inquiets à cause du bric site en 2016
cette nation du royaume uni avait
nettement rejeté la sortie de l'union
européenne avec 62% des suffrages
dans les rues d'aberdeen troisième ville
du pays et plaque tournante européenne
de la pêche et du pétrole en mer du nord
ce sentiment pro us affichent clairement
oui je crois bien
d'autant que mes ancêtres étaient
français ça nous fait remonter loin
c'est vrai bien sûr je me sens même plus
européen que britannique je dirais c'est
typique des écossais de ressentir ce
score testing avec ma femme on adore
l'europe
on est souvent allé en voyage là bas on
a des amis européens donc sans aucun
doute nous sommes européens
les écossais se sent d'autant plus
proche de l'union qu'ils ont
l'impression d'avoir été floués par
westminster en 2014 les écossais avaient
dit non à leur indépendance pour rester
arrimée au royaume uni la garantie
espérait-il d'être toujours dans
l'europe mais en 2016 ce calcul se
retrouvent anéanti par le brr exit à
l'université d'aberdeen l'une des
meilleures au royaume uni certains
étudiants en politique comme wade 18 ans
déplore un déficit démocratique
c'est étrange parce que je devrais
normalement me sentir bien et vis-à-vis
des hommes politiques qui me représente
et qui veulent le meilleur pour moi mais
en fait j'ai surtout l'impression qu'ils
ne sont pas capables de faire quoi que
ce soit je crois que le bric site à
démontrer l'obsolescence du système
parlementaire britannique et les
divisions à turin
pour s'affranchir de londres l'idée d'un
nouveau référendum sur l'indépendance
refait surface dans la société
près d'un habitant sur deux est
favorable cette idée le parti
indépendantiste au pouvoir le snp là
martèle depuis des années lors de son
congrès annuel
les élus présents notamment christian
allard y croit plus que jamais pour
diable m tout est de la faute de
westminster valoir cet eurodéputé
d'origine française représente l'ecosse
à bruxelles et pour lui le pays est mûr
pour l'indépendance à en croire la
progression du parti
on n'a pas vu venir nous avions vingt
mille adhérents dans le snp avant le
référendum pour l'indépendance en 2014
et nous voilà maintenant 120 mille
adhérents cet engouement sans précédent
pour l'indépendance la première ministre
écossaise compte bien l'utiliser pour
faire plier boris johnson
ce jour là dans un discours très
offensif nicolas steurs john exige de
londres un nouveau référendum pour 2020
l'espoir par le cost est de devenir une
nation indépendante
alma et je l'appelle de mes voeux à ce
que ce référendum soit organisé l'année
proche avenir
alors tenez vous prêts mais obtenir
l'indépendance peut être une voie risque
et si elle l'obtient les causes devra
candidater à nouveau pour entrer dans
l'union
sans certitude de remplir à court terme
les conditions économiques et juridiques
nécessaires
de leur côté les cadres du snp comme le
ministre en charge du break si michael
russell se montre confiant à gérer la
femme je crois qu'on est un membre de
lieux sont plus petits que l'ecosse nous
sommes un pays prospère au niveau
d'éducation élevé
et puis nous avons beaucoup de
ressources naturelles des produits qui
s'exportent dans le monde entier et pas
seulement du whisky traçons donc notre
route
c'est pour ça qu'on doit pouvoir choisir
et devenir membre de l'europe
peu après le discours de nicolas star
john le tender ning street a fait savoir
qu'un référendum de cette nature était
un événement unique organisé une fois
par génération
la marche vers l'indépendance pourrait
encore être longue
[Musique]
et pour prolonger le débat j'accueille
sur ce plateau frédéric verreault
bonjour vous êtes professeur en droit de
l'union européenne ici à l'université de
strasbourg et vous intervenez également
à l'ena l'école nationale de
l'administration bienvenus richard
corbett bonjour vous êtes heureux
députés britanniques depuis 2014 vous
êtes membre du parti travailliste et
vous siégez donc ici au parlement
européen au sein du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates bienvenue à
tous les deux je voudrais commencer avec
vous un richard corbett dans le
reportage on a entendu un jeune étudiant
écossais roj
qui dit le break site a démontré
l'obsolescence du système parlementaire
et les divisions du royaume uni vous
êtes d'accord avec ce constat de ce
jeune écossais de 18 ans je pense pas
qu'il est allé si loin de dire que le
système le système parlementaire en tant
que tels sont dépassés non mais il y a
bien d'un cuir beaucoup d'inquiétude
parce que le royaume uni a voté pour le
bric site sur base de d'une compagne
tout à fait mensongère en disant que ce
serait facile serait de son problème ce
serait bien pour l'économie tout cela
s'avère être faux et c'est pour ça ils
péché originel
oui c'est ça parce que normalement on
s'attend après un référendum
tout le monde dit voilà ça s'est résolu
on ans mais derrière ça on y va non pas
du tout ce résultat est de plus en plus
contesté il ya eu la semaine passée un
million de personnes à londres pour
manifester pour rester dans l'union
européenne c'est une des plus grandes
manifestations jamais vues
le parlement britannique eux n'arrivent
pas à se mettre d'accord sur un projet
de break 6 donc c'est la crise
alors justement traité après traité ne
sont pas validées par la chambre des
communes le royaume uni était pourtant
souvent cité en exemple une démocratie
la plus vieille démocratie européenne un
modèle de démocratie un parlement fort
là frédéric verreault on en voit quand
même les limites
alors effectivement c'est l'une des
grosses interrogations à qu'on a à côté
de ce qui était soulignée dans le
reportage
et c'est effectivement un parlement
britannique qui est extrêmement divisé
mais avec des divisions il y avait une
division traditionnelle
effectivement entre les conservateurs et
les travaillistes mais l'un c'est un peu
comme la sphère dreyfus en france le
break site il a agi pour finalement
divisé au sein des familles et au sein
des familles politiques et du coup je
pense qu'effectivement ça explique cette
incapacité beaux liens ciblés d'accord
sur quelque chose une crise politique
majeure qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
organiser des législatives anticipées
c'est une solution catia trop bien
organiser un nouveau référendum
maintenant nous avons un gouvernement
qui est minoritaire
or chaque parti politique d'opposition
le travail les libéraux les verts les
nationalistes écossais les nationalistes
gallois
tous soutiennent un nouveau référendum
sur le pré xique ça c'est une bonne
solution
c'est une solution selon vous également
un nouveau référendum pour mettre fin à
la crise soient un référendum soit
effectivement que de nouvelles élections
même si le système interne britanniques
sont une nouvelle élection là avec
quelque chose d'assez de ses complexes
puisque il n'appartient pas au seul
premier ministre de décider de dissoudre
la chambre et de convoquer de nouvelles
élections
la menace d'éclatement du royaume uni
elle et elle est réelle richard corbett
oui en effet les cas c'est l'irlande du
nord on voit aussi pour rester le pays
de galles c'était plus ou moins match
nul
léger majorité pour sortir mais ils ont
changé d'avis en beauté ils ont peu de
temps et l'angleterre a majoritairement
voté pour quitter mais même au sein de
l'angleterre
les grandes villes l'ombre
liverpool-manchester line son vote
newcastle dans le nord ont voté pour
rester cette petite ville qui ont voté
pour qui tu es donc leur l'éclatement du
royaume uni
ça peut arriver là dans l'émoi dans les
années qui viennent fredrik berg
vraiment une des causes qui réclame son
indépendance on l'a vu dans le reportage
alors l'école c'est effectivement ça
fait déjà depuis depuis quelques temps
depuis longtemps calé sur cette
problématique et il s'est senti floué
expliqué je pense que le pays s'est
senti floué au sens où quelque part ils
sont restés dans le royaume uni parce
qu'il y avait les avantages de l'europe
et que du coup s'il y a break site
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
considérer être leur volonté puisque la
majorité était largement en faveur du
rumen en écosse et ils ont l'impression
effectivement que et l'accord tel qu'il
a été négocié par boris johnson renforce
ce sentiment
puisqu'à une sortie totale de l'union
douanière et du marché intérieur ce qui
évidemment n'a fait que l'ecosse se sent
complètement mises devant le fait
accompli qu'elle ne souhaite pas je vous
propose justement d'écouté à ce sujet la
première ministre decosse
on les écoute syncup dao minh penser à
ce qu'ils cela signifierait le pays de
galles rabotées pour sortir de l'union
européenne l'angleterre aussi au pic est
menacée over ipswich irlande du nord
aura le droit de se prononcer sur son
futur
mais les causes sera la seule nation
britannique à sortir de l'union
européenne contre sa volonté et sans
pouvoir se prononcer ce n'est pas juste
c'est purement et simplement un déni de
démocratie 9,1 pc de mon oncle s'est
alors richard corbett on viens de
l'entendre elle parle d'un déni de
démocratie la première ministre
décosse est pourtant si on en revient à
2016 le break site c'est le résultat
d'un référendum dont d'un vote populaire
du coup alors vous vous demandez un
second référendum mais là en fait on
s'en sort on s'en sort pas donc s'il y
avait un deuxième référendum qui
maintenant serait sur un accord précis
où tout le monde peut voir voir dans le
texte un référendum sur l'accord de
sortie sur l'accord de sortie
on dira ce groupe si ce n'est plus comme
il ya trois ans sur l'idée en général
mais sur un break site clair et précis
où les gens peuvent voir où on va à ce
moment là il est possible de voir
beaucoup plus clairement qu'il ya trois
ans tout cas on voit beaucoup plus on
est beaucoup plus au courant de quoi il
s'agit n'y ait un référendum maintenant
c'est comme si on disait aux peuples
voilà vous avez pu nous exprimer il y a
trois ans maintenant écrasé vous vous
devez accepter n'importe quoi que le
gouvernement veut faire c'est pas juste
ça non plus les incertitudes qui planent
sur la sortie accord pas l'accord sortie
pas sorti est-ce que c'est finalement
pas ces incertitudes qui font plus de
mal
au royaume uni le royaume uni est
suspendu aux brics y trabajo alors
effectivement le royaume uni l'est
l'union européenne l'est depuis
certainement déjà trop longtemps puisque
tout ça dure depuis depuis trois ans
c'est indubitablement un facteur qui
renforce ses mouvements de division il
ya les causes il ya aussi l'irlande du
nord qui effectivement est aussi dans
une position où elle se sent de plus en
plus floue et par part effectivement de
ce premier référendum
le royaume-uni est en effet paralysé 509
l'union européenne ont bon c'est un
problème mais ça va pas chez lui par
l'union européenne de fonctionner de
faire autre chose comment on évite de
raviver les vives tensions à la
frontière entre les deux irlande on voit
que c'est très compliqué qui a pas de
solution idéale par exemple du moment où
le royaume uni le gouvernement
britannique t on va sortir de l'union
douanière à saumon de l'union européenne
ont créé une frontières douanières
or phare des contrôles douanières sur
cette frontière qui faisait exergue
entre les villages au sein de
de l'irlande c'est insensé donc le
compromis c'est de le faire on est dans
la merde et ronde entre les deux îles
mais les irlandais du nord ayant une
bonne partie qui sont farouchement
contre ça donc il n'ya pas de solution
facile
fodé baro vous êtes d'accord avec cela
oui je pense qu'il ya peut-être une
chose qui à me tiens pas été expliquées
de front je dirais par par wes winstar
traître et ou par le premier ministre ou
la première ministre de l'époque c'est
qu'effectivement s'il ya une sortie de
l'union européenne irrémédiablement il y
aura un effet frontières même si c'était
fait frontière se traduit à minima par
une attente à la frontière mais c'est
vrai qu'on a un système en europe on a
plus l'habitude d'attendre à la
frontière ouais c'est une chose dont
j'ai absolument plus l'habitude et puis
où on a des chaînes logistiques qui sont
construites en irlande entre l'irlande
et le royaume uni entre le royaume-uni
et le continent entre le continent et le
et l'irlande aussi qu'ils sont des
chaînes logistiques qui suppose qu'il
n'y ait pas d'attentes qui peut
rassembler parmi la classe politique les
britanniques
est-ce qu'il ya encore quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui les rassemble chaque
arbete nous avait fait une comparaison
avec l'affairé dreyfus en france que ça
m'a beaucoup frappé parce que c'est les
divisions sont énormes ce sujet en effet
ça traverse un peu le parti comme je le
disais tout à l'heure tous les partis
d'opposition tous d'un nouveau
référendum pour pouvoir rester dans
l'union rappelez-vous ce qui peut
rassembler c'est le référendum frédéric
verreault qu'est ce qui peut rassembler
les britanniques aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une vision claire de prendre une
décision sur leur avenir
parce que le problème c'est que depuis
trois ans il ya une décision qui n'en
est pas vraiment une on sait pas trop où
on est et cette incertitude je pense
elle elle ne fait que raviver des
divisions qui par ailleurs sont des
divisions profondes de la société
britannique
avant de se quitter je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment richard corbett le
parlement est réuni cette semaine en
séance plénière et c'est peut-être alors
le break site lui a appelé à être très
prudents l'une de vos dernières veut
ici au parlement européen à strasbourg
en tant qu'eurodéputé on fera pas de
sentiments je suis sûr que cela prend
pour la dernière fois que je viens et
c'est en tant qu'eurodéputé d'accord
très bien et ben on aura l'occasion à ce
moment-là d'en reparler
ce sont les mots de la fin merci à tous
les deux c'est la fin de cette émission
vous pouvez la voir en replay sur les
sites internet des chaînes
parlementaires mais aussi sur l'antenne
de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]